bonjour à tous les deux merci d'être ce
matin en direction vers crt france pour
débattre du plan du plan pour lutter
contre le trafic de drogue que va
proposer le chef de l'état aujourd'hui
un grand plan pour la ville de marseille
dont les modalités vont être détaillé un
milliard d'euros c'est colossal franck
allisio qu'en pensez vous
un milliard d'euros c'est peut-être
colossal déjà c'est une promesse qu'il
fait au nom de son successeur puisque je
rappelle qu'on est à huit mois de la fin
de la moins de huit mois de la fin du
mandat de d'emmanuel macron donc tout ça
est une promesse qui ne qui ne tiendra
pas ensuite ça fait cent fois
quand on met de l'argent alors non mais
jamais assez à marseille évidemment
quand il en arrive c'est tant mieux mais
tout cet argent sans le préalable qui
est un vrai programme pour le coup pas
financier mais sur la sécurité ça ne
servira à rien cette recette là la cité
des marronniers que l'on voit depuis
quelques jours sur tout et sur toutes
les chaînes j'ai grandi à 100 m j'étais
à l'école donc avec avec des camarades
qui est un marronnier c'est pas les
quartiers nord ce sont les quartiers est
ce sont les cartes et de classes
moyennes ça veut dire que la nouveauté
c'est que plus aucun quartier plus aucun
territoire mais épargnée par
l'insécurité et les trafics donc la
priorité est le préalable à tous et la
sécurité et marseille n'est pas
particulière set partout en france donc
les marseillais comme tous les français
demandent un choc de sécurité dieynaba
diop il faut un choc de sécurité vous
êtes d'accord avec ça il va mieux le
maquereau a priori veut mettre le paquet
sur sur les écoles sur les transports et
sur la rénovation urbaine est suffisant
selon vous pour en finir avec ces
trafiquants
je dirais que ce plan arrive
malheureusement un peu trop bas
[Musique]
clairement être en campagne le savons
que depuis plusieurs ça fait cinq ans
qu'elle est donc il lui a fallu
quasiment quatre heures et demie pour se
reprendre de la situation désastreuse
qui est à marseille je rends hommage à
mon collègue est une collection qui
maire-adjoint
de marseille et qui tous les jours
auprès du maire essaie de trouver des
solutions je rappelle qu il nous
manquerait avait reçu des mains de jean
de jean louis borloo et de beaucoup
d'autres mères un plan justement pour
les banlieues lamy à l'appel
donc aujourd'hui ils se réveillent à
quelques mois des élections pour ce
faire
redorer son image
le bilan justement de son action dans
ces zones difficiles tout comme dans les
zones dites rurales des intellos cran
c'est un véritable échec
les choses empirent tous les jours pour
vous là l'argent ne ne suffit pas non
plus donc à résorber ce problème
bien sûr que non tout le monde sait que
l'argent ne suffit pas il faut faire les
bons diagnostics c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce qu'on a une
flambée de violence est partout sur
notre territoire il faut d'abord
travailler sur de la prévention
effectivement sur les écoles vous savez
vous avez beau mettre de l'argent à
l'éducation nationale ou essayer de
travailler si vous n'avez pas sur la
mixité sociale c'est à dire que il faut
aussi regarder ce qui pose problème
ils font toujours d'abord faire le
diagnostic
regardez là où on en a besoin et puis
oui où sont les forces de police
la sécurité c'est le rôle régalien de
l'état où est la police c'est la
question il n'y a pas suffisamment de
moyens c'est l'appel de plusieurs élus
ce renfort policier n'a pas été évoqué
pour l'instant dans ce plan il ya une
diplôme pour tenter de résorber la
violence donc dans les quartiers en 40
ans dans les gouvernements successifs
ça a déjà été essayée pour des résultats
que l'on connaît et il ya quatre ans les
ministres des manuels macron était déjà
venu présenter un plan antidrogue
ce nouveau plan qu est ce qu il a de
nouveau et novateur selon vous franck
allisio trois jours sur place et
beaucoup
à grand chose d'étrange ans en plâtre
aux gens sur place je suis hyper un
début de campagne présidentielle il faut
faire parler il faut faire il faut faire
peser en gros parler de quelque chose
c'est comme si c'était fait dans
l'esprit des communicants autour d'
emmanuel macron voilà je pense pas qu'il
y ait quelque chose de nouveau il n'y a
pas de révolution culturelle dans la
manière dont tu t'approches les choses
madame parler de mixité sociale mais il
y aura de nouveau de la mixité sociale
dans tous les quartiers lorsque l'état
français aura décidé lorsque le
gouvernement a décidé un moratoire sur
l'immigration
parce que si on passe notre temps à
importer des problèmes via des nouvelles
des nouvelles populations immigrées on
n'arrive pas à assimiler les gens qui
sont déjà chez nous depuis parfois plus
d'une génération et donc ça ajoute à la
sécurité ça ajoute au problème ça ajoute
au trafic ça tout le monde le sait
personne ne le dit alors je vous raconte
qu'on écoute un une déclaration
justement du chef de l'état c'était en
mai dernier son important plan s'inscrit
vous allez voir dans l'idée que la ville
devrait devenir dans les années à venir
je cite une capitale de la méditerranée
écouter
les conditions de possibilité d'une
réinvention du lieu et d'une
réappropriation sont là avec une
créativité extraordinaire une jeunesse
saisissante une espèce de puissance vous
êtes d'accord avec avec ces propos d'
emmanuel macron madame diop
marseille est une ville formidable
effectivement il y a du talent il ya un
potentiel
absolument important et est située nous
sommes nous sommes dans une des plus
belles villes de france le problème
c'est que elle a été abîmée par des
années de gestion
catastrophique
tout le monde le sait avec justement on
a abîmé la confiance dans la parole
politique parce que la gestion de
monsieur koba elle essaie des choses
dieu qui ne sont absolument pas comment
dirais-je avec les aujourd'hui et la lys
en place essaie tant bien que mal le
pouvoir justement réparer ses erreurs
l'autre soyons clair il faut d'abord que
nous soyons en capacité d'être aux côtés
des différentes populations
je reconnais évidemment le légat
bâtiment du rassemblement national je
vous rappelle juste que marseille c'est
qu'en france et que la majorité des
personnes qui sont là bas ne sont pas
seulement sur l'immigration ils sont
françaises comme vous et moi monsieur
gillioz donc permettez moi de vous
rappeler que la mixité sociale en
scalpant de signer sociale je parle des
gens qui sont dans les difficultés que
la crise sanitaire actuelle a aggravé
donc parlons à l'ensemble justement de
ses habitants qui sont les premiers à
subir justement les problèmes si cette
délinquance qui gangrènent marseille il
faut faire le bon diagnostic il faut se
donner les moyens
mais il faut aussi le mettre là où ils
doivent être utilisés est d'abord
renforçons justement les effectifs ld
sécurité à marseille et ensuite
travaillons sur justement un vaste plan
pour ceux justement servir et donner à
cette jeunesse mais aussi aux habitants
la sécurité auxquels ils ont droit
comment lutter contre la bunkérisation
de de certains quartiers franck allisio
encore une fois le choc de sécurité la
sécurité ça ne doit pas être réservée
aux derniers quartiers un peu enclave
des des quartiers sud chez nous des
quartiers aisés des quartiers chics
ailleurs la sécurité c'est un droit pour
tous y compris pour les plus modestes le
parti le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de politique véritablement
de sécurité c'est-à-dire de moyens
donnés à la justice à la police mais
aussi de la fin du laxisme judiciaire je
suis désolé mais le cette situation
c'est le résultat de 40 ans de laxisme
de laxisme puis comprimées en place par
parler les les gouvernants décoche
socialiste les les amis de madame et et
voilà et c'est cette politique de
laxisme migratoires et de sécurité qui
aboutit à cette situation c'est une
rupture avec ces politiques qu'il faut
faire c'est ce que j'appelle un choc de
sécurité on va écouter la procureure
justement de demain c'est elle qui a
alerté cet été sur l'explosion de la
délinquance écoutez là
depuis le début depuis le début de
l'année
2021 on voit véritablement que ces huit
premiers mois de l'année sont scindés en
deux avec une première partie de l'année
finalement où nous notions assez peu de
règlements de comptes et une
accélération très importantes à partir
du 15 juin de cette année 2000 2021 avec
véritablement une explosion du nombre
des affaires en quelques mois donc en
deux mois franck allisio je vous pose la
question parce que vous connaissez bien
marseille comment vous expliquer cette
explosion soudaine cet été deux des
règlements de compte
oh je pense qu'il ya beaucoup à voir
avec la sortie du dd confinement
découvre of successifs c'est
malheureusement une forme de rattrapage
c'est une forme de rattrapage par
rapport aux conditions aux conditions
sanitaires qui était qui était plus
strictes le je pense que c'est tout
c'est malheureusement si simple que ça
alors emmanuel macron on veut résoudre
le problème en rénovant les écoles il ya
400 écoles corrigez moi si je me trompe
à marseille qui ont besoin d'être
rénovées améliorer les transports
désenclaver les quartiers nord madame
diop plus de mobilité plus de transport
ça vous paraît aussi être une des
solutions après évidemment le renfort
policier
oui évidemment que nous sommes dans une
ville aux mureaux nous avons justement
mis en place la rénovation urbaine et
nous avons amélioré le système justement
de transport et de mobilité on s'éclaire
obstacles et les gens ne doivent pas se
sentir justement assigné à résidence est
donc une des crises est évidemment de
désenclaver les quartiers de faire en
sorte que les gens puissent justement se
mouvoir et justement ne pas être
complètement enfermé dans leur quartier
il faut travailler aussi sur nos
équipements culturels il faut aussi
avoir de l'accessibilité à des activités
il notera que les gens aient
l'impression qu'ils sont oubliés un peu
les derniers dans ce territoire et je
pense vraiment important de combiner
l'ensemble de ces facteurs parce que il
faut justement que c'est quartier se
sentent que justement intégrée à
l'ensemble du territoire et plus vous
désenclaver et moins il y aura de trafic
parce que justement nous ne serons pas
qu'ils soient isolés et que tout ce qui
peut s'y passer puisse être justement
détecter et et qu'on puisse appréhender
les personnes qui ont ce problème ça
dans ces quartiers-là et d'un polo ne
représente que 5% de la population vous
constatez des résultats aux mureaux
grâce à cette folie il devrait novation
mais évidemment évidemment les quartiers
sont beaucoup plus apaisées nous avons
beaucoup moins de
problèmes justement dans le classement
et je vous rappelle que dans les années
90 le dans les années 80 il y avait des
critiques est vraiment très complet m'a
dit clairement la délinquance avait
abaissé nous avons encore une fois mis
en place un plan avec justement la
préfecture de police sur les graves et
des travaux d'intérêts généraux parce
que il ne suffit pas de thunes il faut
aussi réinsérer il suivre justement
c'est plutôt les en priorité les
primo-délinquants si nous voulons
justement enrayer ces problèmes de
délinquance et punir de manière ferme
ceux qui sont récidivistes et qui sont
connus des services de police donc vous
voyez la sécurité mais absolument pas un
sujet tabou pour la gauche elle puisque
nous prenons et justement ce droit à la
sécu comme étant primordiale et ce sont
les gens les gars de l'est sont les
premières victimes franck allisio on est
à huit mois de l'élection présidentielle
regardez ce qu'on pense l'opposition de
ce plan pour marseille
après quatre ans et demi de pouvoir
emmanuel macron a enfin un plan pour
marseille nous sommes sauvés à les
campagnes électorales en visite à
marseille cette semaine macron va
annoncer un plan colossal pour redorer
le blason de la cité ce n'est pas avec
de l'argent que l'on change des
mentalités malheureusement de la com
c'est là comme franck allisio sony
oui clairement c'est clairement de la
com ces 40 la com
c'est encore une fois une bille on aura
beau mettre de l'argent déjà il s'engage
pour cent comptent pour son successeur
donc c'est en plus du cynisme en plus de
la com c'est du cynisme et puis vous
devrez beau quand il ya à chaque fois
qu'il ya de l'argent car ça évidemment
qu'on l'accueille parce qu'évidemment
qu'on est une ville plutôt en difficulté
donc à chaque fois que l'état veut
investir si c'est une bonne chose mais
on aura beau refaire les transports
publics les rénover une énième fois de
rabot refaire et rénover les les grands
ensembles mais c'était donc si les
délinquants et criminels continuent à
agresser dans les transports publics
s'il est des mêmes quand les criminels
continue at il est dans les cages
d'escalier au fait ça ne changera rien
au quotidien des habitants ça ne
changera rien au quotidien des
marseillais si on fait un comparatif la
ville de nice également a fait un plan
de rénovation urbaine dans le quartier
des moulins ça n'a pas apporté non plus
de d'amélioration sur sur ce trafic de
drogue il ya eu 15 morts depuis le début
de l'année on voit des jeunes de plus en
plus jeunes recrutés ils ont même de 9
ans à 10 ans ce qui est extrêmement
préoccupant le fait de mettre le paquet
également sur l'école madame diop
comment ramener ces jeunes sur le chemin
de l'école
bien sûr mais il faut savoir que ces
jeunes en plus souvent son sont en
situation de décrochage scolaire parce
que notre système est très abîmée on
sait très bien que les inégalités se
creusent de plus en plus alors à
l'épreuve les murs de l'école cela va
résoudre le problème ce moment
absolument absolument pas il faut voir
il faut dans les programmes non
seulement il faut aussi remettre les
choses à leur place parce que vous êtes
un enseignant âgé par le nôtre en
connaissance de cause touchant selon lui
sous le professionnel depuis plus de 100
ans vous n'êtes pas un hymne du catr ce
qu'on attend de l'école aujourd'hui
c'est de résoudre les problèmes de la
société or ce n'est pas le rôle des d'un
enseignant ce n'est pas le rôle de
l'école il faut prendre le problème à la
racine c'est-à-dire que si on a des
enfants qui sont en capacité d'être
enrôlé des lâches des 9 10 ans il faut
se poser la question de pourquoi ces
enfants qui se retrouvaient déjà dehors
m avec leurs
activités périscolaires c'est pourquoi
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une vigilance
particulière justement sur ces quartiers
là est ce qu'il y à des aides qui seront
apportées il faut remettre du temps sur
l'éducation populaire c'est-à-dire tout
ce temps qui est en dehors de livres à
l'école 550 jours le reste du temps les
enfants sont dehors il faut que l'état
revienne
ajustements à occuper le terrain ont
tout ce temps qui est charnu cassure
nationale parce que c'est donc ce temps
là que ça se passe c'est pas dans le
camp contre 1 qui est à l'école on a des
problèmes c'est dans le cas à
l'extérieur quand vous avez des rixes
quand vous avez des règlements c'est
pendant le temps de l'école ou à
l'intérieur dispense colère si ou aux
abords ou dans les quartiers donc c'est
là bas qu'ils voient les parents qui
s'inquiètent beaucoup aussi pour leurs
enfants mais qui ne font pas forcément
confiance vous avez vous allez le voir
pardon sur ce sondage 78% des français
ne font pas confiance au gouvernement en
matière de lutte contre la délinquance
franck allisio un commentaire
ouais bah au bout de quatre ans et demi
l'immobilisme comment voulez vous que
les français fassent confiance à ce
gouvernement je veux dire le bilan est
clairement est clairement négatif le miz
intérieur fait un tweet voulait montrer
en tant qu il ya 10 minutes sur il n'y a
pas de zone de non droit en france alors
que lorsqu'il n'était pas ministre de
l'intérieur et lorsqu'il était dans
l'opposition il ya quelques années il ne
cessé de dénoncer ces zones de non droit
évidemment il n'a pas la prétention
d'imaginer qui les a fait disparaître
donc il ya un discours dans l'opposition
un discours lorsqu'on est au pouvoir il
y a toujours toujours la même réalité
celle de l'échec un échec patent sur la
sécurité qui pourrit la vie des français
et particulièrement en l'occurrence des
marseillais au quotidien et on va en
parler dans la deuxième partie de cette
matinale justement avec le frère d'une
des victimes de ces règlements de
comptes à marseille merci beaucoup
franck allisio et et merci à vous deviez
naba diop d'avoir débattu sur ce plateau
en direct merci